[Musique]
salut à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur rt france pour la grande interview
aujourd'hui notre invité charles cohen
qui est à la tête de l'application body
guarda une application qui lutte
notamment contre le harcèlement sur
internet et les propos haineux bonjour
charles cohen merci d'être d'être notre
invité première question toute simple
charles kuen pourquoi avoir créé cette
application quel est son but
quel est son fonctionnement est ce que
vous pouvez nous la présenter bonjour à
tous merci de me recevoir
alors l'application bodyguard vient de
deux trois choses en fait je les crée
donc il ya maintenant trois ans vers 21
heures non la première chose c'est une
application qui me correspond sur le
plan un petit peu personnel dans le sens
où je me cale et craint on va dire de
bon qui a une volonté d'avoir un impact
positif
un petit peu sur le monde donc c'est
vraiment la retranscription un peu de ce
que je veux être et de ce que je veux
faire en tant qu'être humain la deuxième
chose c'est de la volonté de lutter
contre le fléau de la haine en ligne qui
fait quand même 60 suicides par an en
europe et on parle la limite que des
suicides mais ça fait également beaucoup
d'autres dommages qui peuvent être très
graves et la troisième chose c'est de
lutter contre quelque chose qui est en
train d'apparaître qui est assez grave
c'est l'autocensure
on a de plus en plus de gens de
journalistes ou même des gens comme moi
qui n'osent pas qui n'ose plus exposés
s'exprimer publiquement sur internet de
peur de se faire insulter ou moqués et
ça c'est très très grave
dans les mois et les années à venir donc
il faut faire quelque chose dès
maintenant
c'est pour ça que j'ai créé donc là la
société bodyguard où on a développé une
technologie qui repère avec une
précision proche de 100%
les contenus haineux sur internet et on
a pris cette technologie on l'a mise
dans deux solutions on l'a mise dans une
première solution qui est une
application mobile gratuite pour
protéger les individus du cyber
harcèlement et des contenus haineux et
on l'a mise dans une autre solution pour
aider également les entreprises à lutter
contre ce fléau est donc à peuvent
utiliser notre technologie pour protéger
et modérer leurs plateformes et comment
ça marche exactement
alors comment ça marche est assez simple
on télécharge l'application c'est
gratuit
pas de publicité il n'y a pas de
collecte de données on télécharge
l'application se connecte avec un ou
plusieurs de ces réseaux sociaux une
fois qu'on est connecté une fois qu'on
va se connecter pour la première fois on
va venir personnaliser sa modération
c'est à dire que bodyguard détecte huit
catégories de haine vous protège de huit
catégories de haine on a les insultes
les moqueries sur le physique
l'harcèlement morale l'harcèlement
sexuel les menaces de mort le racisme et
l'homophobie et pour toutes ces
catégories l'utilisateur va pouvoir
définir la sévérité de modération qu'il
souhaite et donc c'est vraiment
l'utilisateur qui a la main sur sa
protection et c'est l'utilisateur qui
fixe ce qui fixe son propre curseur donc
par exemple pour un utilisateur qui
n'est pas forcément touchés par les les
insultes il va pouvoir dire bon bah moi
les insultes soit je veux pas aller je
veux pas les retirer ou soit je veux es
protéger uniquement des pires insultes
mais les insultes un peu bas de bas
niveau je veux les laisser et donc une
fois qu'on a personnalisé sam sa
modération
on va personnaliser la réaction de
bodyguard c'est à dire qu'une fois que
bodyguard a repéré un contenu haineux on
va lui dire ce qu'on veut qu'il fasse
donc ça peut être retirer le contenu de
la plateforme ça peut être bloquée
l'auteur du contenu masqué l'auteur du
contenu et une fois qu'on a fait ça on a
juste à fermer l'application on a juste
à utiliser ces autres applications
normalement et ce qui va se passer
finalement c'est que bodyguard va venir
analyser tous les commentaires sous vos
vidéos youtube sont vos photos instagram
les gens qui vous mentionne sur twitter
on analyse ses contenus en temps réel on
les récupère et si la technologie les
détecte comme haineux selon vos critères
de modération on va retirer le contenu
de la plateforme on va faire l'action
que vous souhaitez donc c'est aussi ça
fait ça vous avait énuméré numéro huit
types de cyber harcèlement qui sont
généralement les victimes je suppose que
vous avez été en contact avec des
victimes de haines en ligne comment se
traduit leur souffrance notamment
alors on a maintenant en france du moins
plus de 50000 utilisateurs parmi ces 50
minutes il y thater c'est très varié on
de tout on a des journalistes on a des
ministres on a des acteurs des très gros
youtuber des gens comme moi c'est super
varié on protège tout le monde on est
très content de ça ça se traduit comment
ça se traduise enfin le le les victimes
de l en ligne généralement il y a
plusieurs effets très néfastes
on parle souvent du pire qui est le
suicide il ya bien d'autres choses
plusieurs choses qui sont avant et qui
sont tout aussi graves il y en a qui
sont victimes de dépression il y en a
qui ont ce vont subir à qui on peut
avoir confiance en eux pendant trente
ans il y en a qui vont être un peu
humilié aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
parce que le cyber harcèlement est
visible il y en a qui dans les zones
nombre de suicides tout à l'heure à ce
que vous avez d'autres d'autres chiffres
sur les dépressions sur sur d'autres
types de souffrances on n'a pas les
chiffres exacts sur le le sait autre
type de souffrance mais par contre on
sait que il ya à peu près un enfant sur
deux en france qui est soit victime soit
hauteur de cyber violence sur internet
donc c'est quand même extrêmement grave
et c'est finalement peu connu
les parents ne font aussi pas forcément
attention parce qu'ils disent ah mais
non mais moi mon enfant il est super
bien éduqué dans la vraie vie dans la
vie réelle on va dire il ne ferait
jamais ça donc il ya aucun problème mais
ils se doutent pas en fait qu'ils aient
une chance sur deux qu'ils soient soient
auteurs soit victime de ça et ça peut
être très très grave et c'est pas ça
peut avoir des conséquences très graves
aussi au niveau de l'enfant au niveau de
ses résultats scolaires au niveau de son
intégration dans la dans la dans la vie
c'est là où tout se forment et donc
c'est un problème très grave qu'il faut
résoudre dès maintenant finalement et
comment est ce que vous expliquer cette
recrudescence de haine en ligne est ce
que par exemple le confinement il est
pour quelque chose
alors exactement je pense que c'est
important de ne pas parler de haine en
ligne et de vraiment mexique et les
différents types de haine et dif est
décortiqué les différents type
d'attaquant et d'attaqué je pense que
vous allez avoir peut-être quelques
questions sur des lois ou sur
l'actualité et pour bien répondre à ça
je pense que c'est important de déjà dès
le départ posé des bonnes bases parce
que on a fait quelques erreurs sur la la
france a fait quelques erreurs sur la
communication en parlant de haine en
ligne
les no line c'est ça n'existe pas
linehan l'insee soit d'un côté du cyber
harcèlement des cyber violent
ce qu'ils sont des contenus haineux
destiné à une personne en particulier où
on a les discours de haine qui sont des
contenus et ne destinait un groupe de
personnes de par leur religion leur
couleur de peau leur sexualité etc et
d'un point de vue attaque en attaque et
on a également les jeunes et on a de
l'autre côté on va appeler ça les
boumeurs enfin les personnes un peu plus
un peu plus âgé et c'est vraiment deux
profils différents parce que selon les
catégories d'attaquants ou d'attaqué
c'est pas le même type de haine chez les
personnes un peu plus âgées notamment
sur facebook ça va être beaucoup dans le
discours de haine
là où chez les enfants ça va être dans
le cyber harcèlement donc c'est
quelqu'un que c'est quelque chose
d'important déjà à décortiquer et je
vous avoue que j'ai oublié votre
question qui était ma question c'était
de savoir comment est ce que tout cela
se traduisait si vous aviez si vous
aviez des chiffres et je voulais savoir
également parce qu'on vous avait parlé
de profil mais est ce qu'il existe un
profil type un portrait robot par
exemple de l'attaquant notamment on
parle beaucoup d'anonymes a notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux certains sont
pour l'anonymat certains sont contre
l'anonymat
quid de sa exactement il y avait aussi
la question sur la recrudescence
en effet il ya une recrudescence depuis
maintenant un an deux ans pourquoi parce
que les personnes sont connectées de
plus en plus tôt et plus en plus tard
sur les réseaux sociaux et l'actualité
un petit peu social et économique du
pays fait que les gens soient un petit
peu plus énervé un petit peu plus tendu
et donc ils utilisent encore plus les
réseaux sociaux comme défouloir pour un
petit peu se lâcher et donc c'est ce qui
explique une augmentation de 56% des
contenus haineux lors du premier
confinement et de 32%
lors du second confinement donc c'est
quelque chose qui va s'accentuer c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut suivre de très
près en termes d'attaquants on n'a pas
vraiment d'attaquants ça peut vraiment
venir de partout parce qu'il ya
justement ce côté défouloir et déversoir
de haine
donc on a des attaquants et des attaques
et qui sont de tous profils de tous
bords de tout parti politique
et c'est pas possible d'établir un
schéma type là dessus
ce qui est d'autant plus qu'on va venir
je voulais revenir là dessus sur
l'anonymat sur sur les réseaux sociaux
certains sont pour certains sont contre
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire selon vous
honnêtement je ne suis pas je ne suis
pas pour l'interdiction de l'anonymat
sur les réseaux sociaux parce que je
pense que ça ne résoudrait pas le
problème
vous pouvez dès maintenant aller sur ces
années je sais pas moi dans un café le
plus proche se connecter au wifi public
et propager de la haine même si vous
n'êtes pas même si vous êtes des
anonymisées on n'arrivera jamais à vous
retrouver
donc c'est d'un point de vue logistique
d'un pendu technique c'est impossible à
mettre en place et ça ne résout pas le
problème on va en parler mais c'est
comme bannière donald trump de twitter
ça ne résout pas le problème ça fait que
le déplacer le problème
il est bien plus profond il est aussi
ont partie liée à l'actualité sociale et
économique des pays
et s'il ya aussi une question énormément
d'éducation donc pour répondre à ce
genre de problème la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer mais c'est pas finalement en
bannissant un profil d'un réseau social
en supprimant un commentaire qu'on va
forcément systématiquement résoudre le
problème parfois on fait que le le le
finalement le déporter un petit peu dans
le temps on fait que l'accentuer
et c'est pas une solution seine d'avenir
pour revenir à la création de votre
application bodyguard pour les raisons
d'avoir créé
cet outil est ce que vous avez vous
expérimentez quelque chose de personnel
à ce niveau est ce que vous avez été
victime de cyber harcèlement alors je
n'ai jamais été victime de cyber
harcèlement j'ai été victime comme je
pense énormément de jeunes d'autocensure
dans le sens où il ya une période de ma
vie forcément où je n'osais pas
m'exposer m'exprimer publiquement sur
internet sur youtube
de peur de me faire moquer ou insulter
et ça c'est un vrai problème c'est un
franc à la liberté d'expression c'est un
frein à la création
et oui ça pour moi comme la plupart des
jeunes dont a été victime de ça il ya
encore des jeunes qu'ils sont encore
actuellement voire même d'aider les
moins jeunes
charles cohen rester avec nous embarque
une courte pause en revient dans un
instant sur rt france dans la grande
interview pour continuer à parler de
cyber harcèlement et de tout ce qui est
plus actuel
[Musique]
de retour sur arte france la grande
interview notre invité est toujours là
il s'agit de charles cohen qui est le
fondateur de l'application à bodyguard
qui luttent contre les propos haineux et
la haine en ligne charles cohen on parle
beaucoup en ce moment l'actualité parle
beaucoup de la loi contre les
séparatismes religieux rebaptisé projet
doit confortant les principes
républicains dans lequel il va y avoir
des dispositions contre la haine en
ligne je pense notamment au délit de
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
est-ce suffisant selon vous vous avez
énuméré un 8 8 catégories de
cyber-harcèlement je suppose que la
haine en ligne par rapport aux religions
fait partie je pense que c'est déjà
super important d'améliorer la
communication vis-à-vis de cette loi et
vis-à-vis de la haine en ligne encore
une fois on reparle de haine en ligne
comme pour la loi a bien et on va
retomber dans le même problème ça va
faire peur on va penser on avoir peur de
la sueur censure et du coup ça va être
rejetée donc c'est important de
d'arrêter de paraît finalement donné
dans l'idée de commencer morceau par
morceau attaquants selon les profils
d'attaquant et d'attaqués et si on
commence comme ça petit à petit on
arrivera à terme à une loi complète bien
formés et qu'ils se rassurent tout
accepter mais oui c'est important de s'y
attaquer dès maintenant et pour moi
c'est également important de laisser le
choix à l'utilisateur pourquoi parce que
la loi est bien supprimer ce type de
contenu c'est bien c'est normal ça va
être dans la loi mais on ne résout pas
forcément le problème
on a juste le déplacer on va le aux
déportés et c'est même type de contenu
pour se retrouver sur d'autres
applications non contrôlée non modérés
ça ça va poser également un très très
gros problème mais qu'est ce que vous
proposez alors le délit de mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui par exemple ce
n'est pas suffisant alors il faudrait
non seulement retirer les contenus je
suis d'accord mais derrière il faut
avoir une action très rapide en justice
poursuivre les auteurs de ces contenus
est tout de suite pouvoir agir si on
fait que supprimer un contenu en ligne
et c'est tout derrière on ne résout pas
le problème il faut avoir plus de moyens
pour qu'on puisse et supprimer le
contenu est derrière pouvoir sanctionner
les auteurs de ces contenus donc il faut
une meilleure collaboration entre la
justice et les plateformes et les
réseaux sociaux
le problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas cette
collaboration actuellement et que dès
qu'on demande si on peut avoir des
informations sur certains utilisateurs
on nous demande d'aller demander aux
états unis et là pas de réponse donc
simplement supprimer le contenu
ça va juste accentuer le problème selon
moi je ne dis pas que j'ai la science
infuse et que j'ai je résous forcément
le problème mais ça va juste poursuivre
écrit accentuer le problème mais pour
ensuite poursuivre la personne qui est
l'auteur de ces contenus si elle est
anonyme comment est ce qu'on fait alors
y'a jamais vraiment personne qui anonyme
on a aussi la notion de d'adressent ip
qui permet de retrouver les auteurs mais
alors encore une fois comme je disais
tout à l'heure si la personne est dans
un café sur un oui si public on ne
pourra jamais savoir qui a posté sa donc
en effet la réponse aux il faut amener
une réponse forte à ce problème par la
suppression des contenus mais derrière
il faut trouver les bonnes solutions
pour derrière pour voir condamner les
personnes dans la vraie vie
sinon on ne résout pas le problème et je
dis pas que j'ai forcément la solution à
ça moi j'attaque l'aspect en ligne
l'aspect digital en avec bodyguard
étant donné qu'on laisse la main à
l'utilisateur on résout un problème
éthique assez important c'est à dire
qu'on n'impose pas notre modération à
tout le monde et si vous n'êtes pas
content c'est pareil c'est ce qu'a fait
twitter dernièrement et tous ces
utilisateurs se sont retrouvés sur
l'application par les qui est finalement
un concentré de haine en ligne non
contrôlée et très grave donc à nous
aussi de voir comment on peut attaquer
ce problème d'un point de vue éthique
d'un pendu règles de modération est ce
qu'on laisserait pas un peu plus le
choix
l'utilisateur pour éviter justement ces
phénomènes là mais de parler de
l'actualité évidemment il ya donald
trump les états unis quel rôle pour les
réseaux sociaux le président américain
sortant qui a été banni de twitter de
facebook de youtube plus récemment la
classe politique en france est unanime
qu'elles soient pro ou anti tron
qu'elles soient de gauche ou de droite
condamnent ces agissements de la part
des grandes plateformes américaines
certains parlent de privatisation de la
justice et qui doit prendre ce rôle de
régulières de régulateur l'état les
gaffes un autre acteur plus neutre alors
pour moi quand il s'agit d'un
bannissement si général pour moi ce
n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux réseaux
sociaux a donc à des entreprises privées
de prendre cette décision mais ça doit
être à la justice de prendre cette
décision
exactement comme ils font avec les
fournisseurs de services internet où il
ordonne le le bannissement et le
blacklistage de certains sites internet
mais ça doit pas venir des opérateurs
eux-mêmes mais ça doit venir de la
justice parce que ça peut avoir des
répercussions très graves
on l'est on a vu récemment le les big
for donc les gaffes à s'organiser pour
annuler finalement veulent lakansyèl
culture salon de las pour annuler
quelqu'un sur internet ce que quelqu'un
s'était donald trump
on les a vus également en oeuvre pour
annuler une application comme parler qui
était une alternative aux réseaux
sociaux bien ou pas bien ça c'est un
autre débat
le problème c'est qu'ils ont le pouvoir
d'annuler une boîte d'annuler une
personne peu importe le pouvoir qu'elle
a et ça ça va poser des problèmes alors
oui ça reste une entreprise privée etc
leurs conditions d'utilisation
mais est ce qu'on peut vraiment encore
parler d'entreprises privées sachant que
maintenant que la création toute la
communication se fait sur internet et
via ses réseaux sociaux là donc selon
vous il faut qu' il y a un arsenal
juridique suffisant alors on se souvient
vous ne vous vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure la loi via un qui était dans les
tablettes de l'exécutif la loi via donc
sur les contenus haineux sur internet
elle a été retoquée par le conseil
constitutionnel car jugée liberticide ça
pose donc une question sur sur la
liberté d'expression telle est la limite
entre protection des individus et
liberté d'expression on dit souvent que
la liberté s'arrête là où commence celle
des autres
exactement ça c'est super et une erreur
de la loi via ça a été de tout mettre
dans le même panier sous le sous le nom
et no line donc forcément ça fait peur
ça fait peur ça fait sur censure et ça
ça inquiète
et dans ce cas là en effet on peut avoir
peur pour notre liberté d'expression il
aurait fallu une meilleure communication
décortiquant les différents problèmes
les différents types de haine les
différents types de profils d'attaquant
et d'attaqués et d'attaquer partie par
partie
le cyber harcèlement qui sont des
contenus haineux dessiner une personne
en particulier
c'est primordial de les retirer le plus
vite possible parce que un contenu
haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à une
fillette de 8 ans va te suicider ça ça
doit être retirée immédiatement il n'ya
aucun débat à avoir sur ce retrait là
parce que ça ça fait des suicides sur ce
côté là il n'ya aucun débat à voir et on
aurait dû déjà avoir une loi et c'est
déjà je m'énerve
on aurait déjà la loi le condamne déjà
c'est déjà interdit de faire ça bien sûr
mais c'est juste que les gaffes à ne
l'appliquent pas la justice est lente et
c'est très problématique
donc il ya besoin d'une mise à jour sur
tout ce qui est lié aux cyber
harcèlement
il n'existe pas déjà un gendarme relais
des réseaux sociaux
on sait qu'il ya par exemple la cnil un
le gendarme du du web pour protéger les
données
la commission nationale de l'intérêt de
l'informatique et des libertés mais par
rapport aux réseaux sociaux les il
existe rien du tout c'est ce que vous
dites il n'existe pas grand chose les
réseaux sociaux n'applique pas forcément
les lois où il ya la plateforme pharos
qui est super mais malheureusement ils
sont en sous-effectifs et ils sont
submergés de demandes et il ya les
réseaux sociaux bien sûr qui retire les
contenus mais retire des contenus après
une vérification humaine et ça met trois
à quatre jours même si ça met une heure
c'est déjà trop le mal est déjà fait
donc c'est pas possible de continuer
comme ça et on doit travailler sur une
loi sur ce niveau là pour tout ce qui
est discours de haine pour moi là il ya
débat pour tout ce qui est discours de
haine
leleu la vision qu'on a chez body guard
c'est de laisser la main à l'utilisateur
est serré ce tir de loisir ou non s'il
souhaite voir ses contenus là vous
parlez de haine mais à partir de quand
le messager et ne également où placer le
curseur également c'est ça qui est très
compliquée où placer le curseur c'est
pour ça que le problème également des
plateformes c'est lui qui fixe leurs
propres curseur je dis pas que c'est
bien ou pas bien je dis juste que ça
l'aise certaines personnes qui se
sentent sont sûrs et censurer et ça
laisse d'autres personnes qui disent
mais moi c'est pas assez suffisant selon
moi d'où l'importance de laisser la main
à l'utilisateur c'est ce qu'ont fait
derrière l'application mobile bodyguard
on donne des exemples concrets et au
moment où elles vont personnaliser leur
modération et comprennent
oué peuvent placer le curseur et quels
sont les types de contenus haineux qui
seront retirés ou pas j'ai tendance à
dire chez body guard que nos règles de
modération pour déjà pour 95% des
contenus retiré par mégarde ce sont des
contenus illégaux donc à la limite il y
aurait même pas besoin d'avoir de de
débat là dessus mais de manière générale
bodyguard retire ce que les gens osent
dire derrière un ordinateur sous couvert
d'anonymat
mais n'oserait pas dire dans la vraie
vie devant la personne et ça on se rend
compte que généralement ça couvre 95 %
de ces contenus lassé des contenus
haineux et c'est un un vrai problème
j'aime bien là le j'aime bien le
fonctionnement de bodyguard pourquoi
parce que on a d'un côté l'attaquant qui
postent son contenu haineux qui lui a sa
liberté de poser d'envoyer son contenu
haineux mais il ne peut pas forcer son
destinataire à le lire donc son
destinataire est également la liberté de
ne pas vouloir le voir
suite à la création de votre application
est ce que vous êtes en contact avec des
politiques avec le gouvernement même
peut-être avec avec les instances
européennes on souvient après laffaire
samuel pâtit les politiques français
s'était retourné vers vers l'union
européenne pour essayer de légiférer à
l'échelle européenne
est ce que vous êtes en contact avec
toutes ces personnes là pour trouver une
solution
alors oui on est en contact avec
laeticia via avec les acteurs européens
pour le digital services act on est en
contact avec tous ses acteurs et nous
avec grand plaisir et on discute avec
eux on leur donne notre point de vue on
n'est pas là a tapé bêtement sur les sur
des plateformes ou sur les politiques
au contraire on essaie de les défendre
parfois mais on est en discussion avec
eux et on essaie d'apporter notre point
de vue qui ne va pas forcément résoudre
tous les problèmes du monde je vous la
corde mais qui va selon nous dans le bon
sens c'est la première brique qui va
dans le bon sens 2 pour résoudre ce
problème lié au contenu haineux je parlé
également de l'échelon européen
comment travailler main dans la main
entre les états avec l'europe trouver
des outils juridiques en commun c'est
possible c'est possible et ce sera
nécessaire je pense que c'est au niveau
européen qu'on va résoudre le problème
il faut que la législation viennent au
niveau européen
donc il faut que tous les pays sont
d'accord et tous les pays appliquent
cette loi là mais encore une fois il
faut bien communiquer à propos de cette
loi il faut bien la construire il faut
être clair parce que sinon elle sera
rejetée parce qu'il a ce risque de sur
censure qui peut être dramatique
donc il ne faut pas arriver sur ce sur
ces niveaux là mais il ne faut pas qu'on
arrive sur de la sueur censure imposée
également par les plateformes
donc il faut un peu plus réfléchir un
peu mieux construire tout ça et surtout
communiquer échanger avec les acteurs
concernés pas échangé uniquement avec
les gars ça il ya énormément
d'associations comme par exemple enfance
en france dirigé par justine atlan qui
font du super boulot il faut échanger
avec tous ces acteurs là qu'ils ont leur
mot à dire et qui ont une vision super
intéressante du problème oui que vous
échangez avec les politiques avec
laeticia via notamment la députée m
acronis est à l'origine de
donc de la loi via retoquée par le
conseil constitutionnel
quel est le rôle exact des politiques
dans tout ça en général quel rôle
également de l'éducation nationale par
exemple est ce que vous êtes en contact
aussi avec jean michel blanquer
alors le rôle des par exemple de
laëtitia via qui était de former la loi
ça a été de 2,2 d'échanger avec tous les
acteurs français qui sont concernés par
ce problème là elle ça a été très bien
fait chacun a apporté sa petite brique
pour former tout ça c'est à dire au cas
où quelque chose qui a été très bien
fait la loi
ça a été retoquée au final parce qu'il
ya eu un problème de communication selon
moi et c'était pas assez clair alors que
si on avait fait une loi qui luttaient
dans un premier temps contre le cyber
harcèlement et qui peut éviter qu'une
fille de 12 ans se suicide dans sa
chambre parce que c'est vraiment le cas
et ça arrive pratiquement tous les mois
là je pense qu'il n'y aurait pas du tout
une débat dans un premier temps on
aurait commencé par ça et ça aurait été
pas mal et ensuite on aura attaqué les
autres problèmes pour revenir à ma
question est ce que vous êtes en contact
avec jean michel blanquer rossi par
exemple le ministre de l'éducation
nationale n'est pas en contact avec jean
michel blanquer on est en contact avec
différents acteurs de l'éducation
nationale et pour moi c'est également
super important de dans les cours
d'éducation civique par exemple
d'ajouter cette notion là mais je suis
passé par ses cours d'éducation civique
il faut faire quelque chose de ludique
ya énormément d'acteurs également qui
propose des solutions très ludique pour
attaquer ce problème là via des jeux
vidéo via des chat via plein de choses
il faut utiliser ces solutions là il
faut pas un professeur qui disent à sa
classe bon ben voilà il faut pas
insulter les gens sur internet
ces écoutes d'ailleurs très mal et fort
mais également les parents aussi là
dedans également il faudrait former les
parents c'est pour ça qu'on a développés
nous une solution qui s'appelle
bodyguard pour les familles qui alerte
en temps réel des parents si leurs
enfants sont victimes ou auteurs de
cyber harcèlement sur internet mais ça
ça permet justement de résoudre une
partie du problème
des attaques en attaque et qui sont
jeunes et par l'éducation on peut encore
sauver ces personnes là mais oui il ya
un besoin nécessaire de former les
parents qui pour la génération actuelle
sont a quand même assez perdu je pense
pour que pour les générations futures
le problème sera un peu plus petit parce
que les parents seront un peu mieux
formés quand on vous écoute on a
l'impression finale que le monde de
l'internet que tout ce qui est virtuel
va plus vite que le monde du réel que
tous les problèmes qui se passe sur la
toile prenne du temps être gérés dans la
vraie vie
comment expliquer cette dichotomie entre
le côté rapide du net
il cotait plus lent au final 2-2 de la
vraie vie en fait c'est là-dessus qu'il
faut trouver la solution pour intervenir
rapidement
ça c'est sûr et certain et cédric au
d'ailleurs parlé de ça hier qu'il faut
une formation s'est attardé tony meilhon
l'informatique en france de manière
générale pardon oui vous disiez cedrico
pour nos téléspectateurs c'est le
secrétaire d'état au numérique
oui pardon c'est le secrétaire d'état au
numérique et ils intervenaient la tuyère
en disant ça il faut il faut un petit
peu plus d'éducation d'un point de vue
informatique parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont largués ça va extrêmement
vite que ce soit au niveau des nouvelles
technologies ou au niveau de la
programmation pour mon domaine c'est
extrêmement rapide et c'est très dur de
suivre un petit peu tout ça donc il faut
former les gens au moins sur la base et
il faut un peu fort mais les gens
peut-être à être curieux aller se
renseigner croiser des sources qu'on
arrive aussi sur le problème des faits
que nous mais il faut les former dans ce
sens là internet c'est un puits énorme
d'informations et c'est génial c'est
l'endroit où toute la création se fait
il ya des merveilles qui sont faites
mais il ya des des côtes et un peu plus
sombre qui sont la désinformation la
haine en ligne et tout ça il faut
alerter il faut former alors
malheureusement j'en ai dire que pour
une certaine population actuellement
c'est peut-être déjà trop tard mais en
tout cas pour tous celles qui arrivent
il faut dès le plus jeune âge les former
aux côtés positive d'internet mais
également aux côtés négatifs faut pas
oublier les côtés positifs comme
wikipedia des choses comme ça enfin il
ya plein de choses excellentes sur
internet et on a été un peu moins bonne
mais il faut les former
c'est un message d'espoir donc on va
terminer là dessus merci beaucoup
charles kuen d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur arte france dans son
interview je rappelle que vous êtes le
fondateur de l'application bodyguard qui
luttons contre la haine en ligne et
contre le cyber harcèlement c'est la fin
de cette grande interview rester sur rt
france on se retrouve très vite bail
[Musique]